we have created structure for female
athletes in our team that can compare
with some of the best men's teams
creating were champions creating Olympic
champions that's our primary goal as a
female athlete my biggest challenge is
you have to stay RC and twelve alum care
to try to be on the top as long as
possible to train good to eat good to
sleep good can you shine racing sport I
need to show education really strongly
you know it's they know it's a very
strong factor with our performance
they've realized the importance we need
to make sure that the body functions
stays healthy so they can train without
interruptions and can recover after
every bike race and already 100% next
day my phone is using SMS products
really great and part of the British
Cycling Team so we've already been up to
use it for the last couple of years I
use an SS product every single day that
I'm training amazing I think that you
can test the quality of a good brand
when you take the gels because actually
is the most important products
especially in the races last year in
Flanders I had eight gels in race and
with sis I always felt that I was taking
the right stuff it's what I think about
both on and off the bike to make sure
you have everything that you need to
grow your body correctly because at the
top of the sport there's one two percent
is the difference between a top-ten
bradder to a winner